hoy les voy a hablar de una de mis dos
grandes pasiones la ciencia la otra es
la música eso es para otro día esas
parecerá muy obvio si yo les digo que la
ciencia es importante para nuestras
vidas imagino que es algo fácil de
entender para muchos pero realmente
comprendemos esto muchas personas
confunden a la ciencia con la tecnología
qué es lo que vemos todos los días en
nuestras vidas por ejemplo ese celular o
esa playstation si es que les gustan las
consolas de videojuegos no son realmente
ciencias son productos tecnológicos
ciencia es más bien todo el conjunto de
conocimientos por ejemplo la física la
química la informática la matemática que
han hecho posible el desarrollo la
invención de estos productos
y todo ese conocimiento se obtuvo
gracias a que a lo largo del tiempo
muchos investigadores han usado el
método científico que no es otra cosa
que hacerse preguntas a formular
hipótesis sobre lo que nos interesa y
ponerlas a prueba de experimentos que
abren la puerta cada vez más nuevos
descubrimientos cada respuesta es en
realidad una serie de preguntas nuevas
y también sonará obvio si les digo que
para hacer ciencia se necesita
científicos bueno y de dónde vienen los
científicos científico nace o seas yo
estoy convencido de que todos podemos
ser grandes científicos porque somos
curiosos desde que nacemos es innegable
y nos hacemos preguntas todo el tiempo
para comprender nuestra realidad o sea
que para tener los científicos
necesitamos primero una niña o un niño
muy curiosos y eso es lo más importante
ahora si esta curiosidad es alimentada
con ejemplos experiencias
transformadoras entonces la ciencia se
convertirá para ese niño o esa niña en
una ocasión para toda la vida y eso es
precisamente lo que te pasó a mí cuando
yo era muy niño sentí una enorme
fascinación por la biología todo lo que
estaba vivo mi padre era médico cirujano
y me llevaba a ver sus operaciones era
increíble ver de niño el interior de un
cuerpo humano vivo el corazón por otro
lado mi madre era ginecólogo
tenía imaginen esto una colección de
fetos humanos preservados de diferentes
edades maravillas no poder ver de cerca
a una edad muy temprana de dónde venimos
cómo nos formamos antes de nacer
también me gustaba muchísimo leer sobre
astronomía y cosmología es decir como
los antiguos humanos descubrieron
nuestro planeta aprendieron a
interpretar el cielo los madres el
universo las olviden tremendamente las
películas de ciencia ficción los vuelos
espaciales y trataba siempre de
imaginarme cómo funcionaban esos
superpoderes en mis superhéroes y
supervillanos favoritos esa capacidad de
volar hacerse invisible las radios de
alta energía por todos lados así pues yo
era un niño con muchas inquietudes
muchas preguntas en la cabeza y ese fue
el inicio de todo
bueno a la larga esta curiosidad por los
misterios de la vida me llevó a estudiar
biología en la universidad y luego hacer
una larga carrera como científico e
investigador en alemania
hoy después de muchos años ya estoy de
vuelta que perú y me dedico a estudiar
enfermedades del cerebro utilizando
embriones de peces embriones de peces
cebra son unos peces tropicales de
cuatro centímetros más o menos para sus
embriones miden cerca de un milímetro
son transparentes y es posible manipular
su adn sus genes para que les brinden
las drogas en realidad cualquier célula
que uno quiera de modo que es posible
ver en vivo cómo crecen se desarrollan o
funcionan las neuronas y qué pasa dentro
de ellas cuando fallan o se mueren que
es exactamente lo mismo que ocurre
cuando nuestro cerebro se enferma por
ejemplo cuando sufrimos de alzheimer
depresión autismo o epilepsia entre
otros
quizás alguno de ustedes dirán en el por
qué querría yo voy a estudiar el cerebro
bueno una buena gran razón es porque en
gran medida somos como somos gracias a
nuestros cerebros nuestros pensamientos
emociones percepciones decisiones son
producto de la actividad de nuestros
templos sin ir más lejos en este momento
nos estamos comunicando y entendiendo
porque nuestros cerebros están
recogiendo información y trabajando muy
activamente para procesar
ahora sí les cuento todo esto puede
sonar fácil eso de estudiar el cerebro
explorar el universo pero la
investigación experimental tiene sus
retos también requiere resistencia y
persistencia la resistencia porque uno
debe resolver problemas superar duros
obstáculos la persistencia porque hay
que estar terror porque la ciencia
requiere tiempo y esfuerzo algo siempre
puede salir mal y uno debe saber
insistir y aprender constantemente de
los errores los errores propios y otros
justamente esa curiosidad de la que
hablábamos es la que nos permite superar
la dificultad porque es como un motor
que te mantiene haciendo experimentos
hasta dar con las respuestas que buscas
mucha motivación en realidad
y cuando un experimento funcionaba ya
que es fascinante descubrir cosas nuevas
y ser el primero el saber algo primero
del mundo también es muy emocionante ser
el primero en comunicárselo a la
sociedad
bueno y todo es el conocimiento que nos
da la ciencia para qué sirve en realidad
en primer lugar sirve para explicar el
mundo que nos rodea en mi caso a lo que
me dedico este mundo mío es el cerebro
pero también nos sirve para encontrar
soluciones a problemas concretos de la
sociedad como por ejemplo hoy mismo esta
pandemia del colon hábitos para entender
al virus su transmisión el diagnóstico
las vacunas
yo personalmente asumí el reto de montar
un proyecto para producir aquí en el
menú nuevas pruebas de diagnóstico
molecular es por una vía para encontrar
algunos pruebas más rápidas y baratas
utilizando una tecnología que se llama
repair casa no tengáis crisis por casa y
cuyo desarrollo le acaba de merecer hace
unos días recién que el premio nobel de
química a dos grandes mujeres
científicas de atención chicas un densos
nombres
jennifer terna de la universidad de
berkeley en california y de manifestar
pendiente el instituto max planck en
alemania quiero aprovechar para
contarles la increíble historia de este
premio nobel
hace unos 20 años más o menos se
descubrió que cuando las bacterias son
atacadas por virus ya también son
atacadas por virus ellas se las ingenian
para copiar un fragmento de los genes y
guardar esta información en su interior
es como si les tomaran las huellas
dactilares a sus atacantes y la
registrará en un archivo
así dice un virus las vuelve a atacar
entonces la bacteria ya está preparada y
utiliza esta biblioteca de huellas de
atacantes para compararlas con las del
nuevo atacante y eso es crispar no
crispar casas esta es la parte crispar
es un sistema de reconocimiento y
defensa para las bacterias ahora si las
huellas del nuevo atacante coinciden con
las que la bacteria tiene registradas
entonces el virus es eliminado
cortándole el alguien y para ello la
bacteria tiene una especie de tijera
pequeñitas moleculares conocidas como
proteínas casas y dady bien en la otra
mitad el nombre cruise pero el
reconocimiento casi las tijeritas
y estas enzimas son proteínas que
utilizan este sistema de huellas para
guiarse y llegar hasta el punto exacto
donde tienen que atacar y cortar y
destruir los genes del virus hoy en día
podemos replicar este maravilloso
sistema genético en el laboratorio de
una manera artificial para que para
ubicar y modificar cualquier tipo de adn
con ellos podemos curar por ejemplo
muchas enfermedades corrigiendo
mutaciones decir cambios en el adn que
causan males como el cáncer y la
obesidad o la diabetes y también
detectando y destruyendo patógenos que
nos atacan constantemente como por
ejemplo bacterias virus parásitos en
muchos y eso es justamente lo que
estamos haciendo hoy en mi laboratorio
en el coronavirus es decir utilizamos
este sistema cruise percas para
modificar adn para analizar la saliva de
una zona sospechosa del joven 19 y
averiguar si se ha contagiado de
coronavirus
y esto es sólo uno de muchos ejemplos de
lo que la ciencia puede hacer por
nosotros en una situación de crisis como
la que vivimos hoy
un tipo de ciencia de muchos tipos de
ciencia ahora la ciencia es una
actividad habitual muy respetada en todo
el mundo pero cómo está la ciencia
hasta la pandemia no era un tema muy
popular no se hablaba mucho de ciencia y
había poca difusión de los medios
hoy sabemos que tenemos científicos
brillantes pero los conoce
tenemos algunos grandes centros de
investigación pero no pueden funcionar
bien porque el gobierno le da muy poco
presupuesto y sin embargo gracias a esta
crisis del coronavirus ahora tenemos una
gran oportunidad para cambiar esto por
un lado podemos pedirle al estado del
gobierno que por fin apueste por la
ciencia que ponga más ciencia en la
educación y por otro lado podemos
involucrar nosotros mismos en hacerse
si es que vivía hubiese futuros
científicos y científicas entre ustedes
es fundamental que persigan sus sueños
esos sueños grandes que nos hagan
realidad que convenzan a sus padres que
esto vale la pena porque si los padres
también pueden aprender mucho sus hijos
y si no se ven a sí mismos haciendo
ciencia entonces es importante que al
menos todos nosotros como sociedad
logremos entender la ciencia apreciarla
y compartirla porque el conocimiento que
se obtiene gracias a la ciencia es la
mejor arma contra la ignorancia la
desinformación los face news por ejemplo
y el atraso en general
por eso que hace unas semanas hicimos
tendencia en redes el hashtag sin
ciencia no hay futuro sin ciencia no hay
futuro es un mensaje poderoso con el que
queremos decirle a nuestra sociedad que
la ciencia es necesaria que con ella
podemos mejorar el país también porque
no eventualmente cambiar el mundo
si ustedes anhelan ciudades sin
contaminación ni tráfico sin
enfermedades ni animales en peligro de
extinción la ciencia es una gran
herramienta para lograrlo
si ustedes sueñan con viajar al espacio
comprender los secretos de la mente o
imaginan medios de comunicación ultra
rápido mejores alimentos la ciencia no
harán posible estamos acostumbrados a
que los grandes inventos y
descubrimientos vengan del extranjero
pero he venido yo aquí a decirles que
ustedes pueden ser quienes logran todo
esto aquí hay muchos tipos de ciencia
para todos los gustos así que hacer que
sea ella disfrútenlo recuerden que esa
curiosidad que sienten ahora de niños y
jóvenes no tiene por qué extinguirse
cuando sean adultos porque los pueden
llevar a una vida llena de
descubrimientos e inventos en beneficio
de la humanidad
así que recuerden sin ciencia no hay
futuro pero si ustedes hacen suya la
ciencia el futuro será vuestro muchas
gracias por escucharme y hasta pronto